so following breaking news this morning
in fact we just got some new information
Metro investigating a shooting involving
police near Charleston and lamb let's
send it out to Lauren negrady with the
very latest
that's right good morning this was a
confirmed officer-involved shooting it
all started as a kidnapping call from
Boulder City police officers out here in
Metro look into the car at 2 A.M near
Owens and Hollywood where the pursuit
came out over here you could see over
here the car's still right there that
white truck now this was a kidnapping
again there were four total people in
the car three victims one suspect that
suspect has been taken to the hospital
critical condition we're gonna have more
for you later on for now live Charleston
and lamb Lauren ready eight news now